supongamos que tengo un sitio web el
cual actualmente tiene este fondo blanco
y supongamos que yo conozco la media del
tiempo que pasan las personas en el
sitio web digamos que es 20 minutos y me
interesa hacer algún cambio para que las
personas aumenten la duración de la
visita de mi sitio web así que decido
cambiarle el color a mi página web y
ahora la voy a tener de color amarillo
mi idea es hacer el fondo de este sitio
web ahora de color amarillo una vez
hecho el cambio como puedo cerciorarme
de que el cambio y logro el impacto
deseado para esto tenemos las pruebas de
significancia para empezar a establecer
el hace hipótesis
la hipótesis nula y la hipótesis
alternativa
la hipótesis nula consiste en la
aseveración oye tu cambio no tuvo ningún
impacto nada nuevo paso al hacer este
cambio por lo que será que tu media aún
es igual a 20 minutos después del cambio
en este caso del fondo amarillo también
tendremos la y
alternativa y ésta lo que nos va a decir
es que si hay un cambio al tener otro
fondo en mi página web entonces va a
decir que la media ahora es mayor que 20
minutos debido al cambio déjame ponerlo
las personas de hecho están pasando más
tiempo en el sitio web así que la media
es mayor que 20 minutos después del
cambio así que vamos a decir que este es
el primer paso establecer las hipótesis
el segundo paso va a ser tener un nivel
de significarse y ya verás cómo funciona
esto en breve este va a ser un umbral
importante denominado nivel de
significancia usualmente denotado por la
letra griega alfa
los valores más usuales son cero puntos
10.01 0.05 1% 5% 10% aunque pudiera
haber otros y en este caso vamos a
aplicar este nivel de significancia
igual am bueno digamos que va a ser
igual a 0.05 lo que vamos a hacer ahora
es tomar una muestra de las personas que
visitan el sitio web el cual ya cuenta
con el nuevo fondo amarillo y a esas
personas le vamos a calcular los ere
estadísticos la media muestral la
desviación estándar muestral y vamos a
pensar que si suponemos que la hipótesis
nula es verdadera cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener una muestra
cuyos estadísticos sean los que
encontramos y si esa probabilidad es
menor que nuestro nivel de significancia
si esa probabilidad es menor que 0.05 es
decir el 5% entonces rechazaremos la
hipótesis nula y tendremos evidencia
la validez de la hipótesis alternativa
por otro lado si la probabilidad de
obtener los estadísticos que calculamos
de la muestra es igual o mayor al nivel
de significancia no podemos rechazar la
hipótesis nula por lo que no tendremos
evidencia para sustentar la hipótesis
alternativa que haremos entonces en lo
que voy a denominar el paso 3 bueno el
paso 3 es tomar una muestra
supongamos en este caso que tomamos una
muestra de n igual a 100 personas estas
100 personas van a visitar a nuestro
nuevo sitio web es decir el sitio web
con el fondo amarillo y calculamos los
estadísticos de la muestra
imagínate que calculamos la media de la
muestra y resulta que la media de la
muestra en este caso es de 25 minutos y
por otra parte también vamos a obtener
si no conocemos la desviación estándar
de la población como suele suceder
entonces podemos calcular la desviación
estándar de la muestra
en el siguiente paso vamos a calcular el
valor p
qué significa valor de probabilidad que
es la probabilidad de obtener un
estadístico que o se ubique por lo menos
a esta distancia con respecto a la media
de la población suponiendo que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera podemos
entonces calcular nuestro valor p en
este caso estamos hablando de una
probabilidad condicional vamos a tener
la probabilidad de que nuestra media de
la muestra al tomar un tamaño de muestra
de n igual a 100 esta media de la
muestra sea mayor o igual que 25 minutos
esto dado que nuestra hipótesis nula es
verdadera en otros vídeos ya hemos
hablado de esto suponiendo que la
distribución es aproximadamente normal
podemos usar la media muestral podemos
usar nuestro tamaño de la muestra y
también nuestra desviación estándar
muestral quizás usaremos nuestra
district hotel para calcular aprox
cuál va a ser este valor de probabilidad
entonces podremos decidir si rechazamos
o no
la hipótesis nula y entonces en el
siguiente paso déjenme llamarle a este
mi paso número 5 tenemos dos casos si mi
valor p déjame escribirlo mi valor p
es menor que mi nivel de significancia
es decir es menor que alfa entonces voy
a rechazar mi hipótesis nula
puedo asegurar que tengo evidencia para
sustentar mi hipótesis alternativa ahora
también existe el otro caso si mi valor
p es mayor o igual que alfa
déjame ponerlo es mayor o igual que mi
nivel de significancia entonces en este
caso voy a decir que no podemos rechazar
la hipótesis nula no voy a decir que
acepto la hipótesis nula voy a decir que
no rechazó la hipótesis nula y ahora
supongamos que cuando hacemos todos
estos cálculos obtengo un valor p que se
encuentra en este caso imagina que
obtengo un cierto valor p igual a 0.03 y
bueno lo que estaría pasando es que como
es menor que 0.05 que mi nivel de
significancia entonces rechazar en la
hipótesis nula
y tengo evidencia para sustentar la
alternativa y esto debe de tener sentido
lógico pues lo que estaríamos haciendo
es tomar una muestra si suponemos que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera y además que
la probabilidad de obtener dicha muestra
es de 3% es decir de 3 centésimas lo
cual es menor que la probabilidad que
establecimos como umbral es por eso que
la rechazamos y entonces sostenemos la
evidencia ante la validez la alternativa
ahora bien también podría pasar que al
hacer todos los cálculos obtengamos una
p
de no ser digamos una p igual a 0.5 en
el cual estaríamos ahora en este segundo
caso el cual podemos interpretar como al
haber supuesto que la hipótesis nula no
es verdadera es decir que no hay una
modificación por haber cambiado el fondo
de blanco amarillo tendrían el 50% de
probabilidad de obtener este resultado
bien
dado que es mayor que el nivel de
significancia no rechazaría la hipótesis
nula que ocurre a esta situación debido
a que la hipótesis nula es verdadera es
razonablemente posible así que estas son
las bases para las pruebas de
significancia en general y como verás es
aplicable a casi cualquier campo de
conocimiento en el que estés trabajando
ahora hay un punto que quiero dejar
totalmente claro nuestro valor en el que
estamos usando para decidir si
rechazamos o no la hipótesis nuland es
la probabilidad de obtener el
estadístico muestral dado que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera en ocasiones
la gente se confunde preguntándose esta
es la probabilidad de que la hipótesis
nula sea verdadera
dado los estadísticos muestrales que
hemos obtenido a lo que yo contesto
categóricamente este no es el caso no
estamos tratando de evaluar la
probabilidad de que la hipótesis nula no
sea verdadera o no lo que estamos
diciendo es fíjate bien suponiendo que
la hipótesis nula es verdadera
cuál es la probabilidad de obtener el
resultado que obtuvimos con nuestra
muestra y si esa probabilidad es pequeña
si es menor que un umbral fijado de
antemano entonces decidiremos rechazar
la hipótesis nula ya que tenemos la
evidencia para sustentar la hipótesis
alternativa eso es todo por este vídeo
nos vemos en el siguiente